so we'll come back at uh hold on let me
let me ring Us in let ring us out all
right I'm going to open up the executive
session for the house committee on
Election law going to recess for 5
minutes until 3:51 one for the purpose
caucus yeah um so today we are looking
at Bill numbers H House Bill 1446 House
Bill 1704 House Bill 1705 and House Bill
3:51
okay it's 351 going to reconvene the
house election law committee um going to
open up the house executive session on
House Bill 1446 let me read the title
um sorry I should have that up
four 4 six thank you um relative to
eliminating the cost for electronic
copies of the checklist uh the uh open
up the floor for debate it be the first
recognize myself uh we have another
vehicle to accomplish this it's House
Bill 1313 uh which is not an early bill
this is an early Bill requires us to act
for February 15th so we have a vehicle
to accomplish this if the committee
seeks to move on this subject is there
any further questions debate hearing
none the clerk will call the Rong I'm
sorry uh sorry is there is there a
motion is there a motion I'm sorry is
there a motion I move itl y we have a
motion for itl is there a
second representative Lane seconds I'll
second thank you now now the clerk will
call the r representative Bo
yes representative Gorski
yes representative quae yes
representative
inberg representative Burnham
yes representative wary
yes representative wood yes
representative
Osborne uh representative
yes representative Paige yes
representative Hammer
yes representative Hamlet yes
representative Mirad yes representative
Bay yes representative Brennan yes
representative Grill yes representative
Howard yes representative rafter
yes uh chairman Barry chair votes yes
with that uh the bill will referred out
as inexpedient to legislate 18 to Z um
I'll handle the committee Report with
that I'm closing the executive session
on house go
1446 and I'm opening up the uh EX ex
cutive session on House Bill 1699
allowing caucus identification of
ballots representative bom is recognized
for a
motion I move itl is there a second I'll
second again representative Lane second
is there any discussion on the
bill hearing none the clerk will call
the role representative B yes
representative Gorski yes representative
quaye yes representative
Ankerberg yes representative Burnham yes
representative warry yes representative
wood
yes representative Osborne
representative kab
oh he was here before I called he manag
to step his foot
in he was it was not okay all right
whatever we'll keep going okay um
representative Lane uh yes
representative
Paige yes representative Hammer yes
representative Hamlet yes representative
Mirad yes representative Bay yes
representative Brennan yes
representative Grill yes representative
Howard yes representative rafter yes uh
chairman Barry chair votes yes with that
um yes we can't put any of these on
consent no they will not be on the
consent count they're all fiscal notes
they all have fiscal notes we are going
to have to what would count on that uh
it's going to be 18 to zero uh which I
well announced uh with that house bill
169 will be reported out of committee um
18 to0 like to take your seat thank you
uh with that we're going to close the
house uh we're going to close the
executive session on House Bill 1699
open up the executive session on House
Bill 1704 relative to the reconciliation
of ballots act representative B is
recognized for a motion I move itl is
there a second I'll second
representative Lane second is there any
discussion on the bill see none the
clerk will call the RO representative Bo
yes representative Gorski yes
representative quy yes representative
Ankerberg yes representative
Burnham oh yes representative wary yes
representative wood yes representative
Osborne yes representative cutab not
here um representative Lane yes
representative Paige yes representative
Hammer yes representative Hamlet yes
representative Mirad yes representative
Bay yes representative Brennan yes
representative Grill yes representative
Howard yes representative rafter yes uh
chairman Barry chair votes yes uh with
that the motion of in speech legislate
passes 19 to0 House Bill 1704 will be
reported out plate I will handle the
committee report I'm going to close the
executive session on House Bill 1704 I'm
going to open the executive session on
House Bill 1705 relative to the
classifying public information
representative bone you recognized for a
motion I move itl is there a second I'll
second that one as well representative
Lane second is there any discussion on
the bill on the motion hearing none the
clerk will call the role representative
Bo yes representative Gorski yes
representative qua yes representative
inberg yes representative Burnham yes
representative warry yes representative
wood yes representative Osborne yeses
kab not here representative Lane yes
representative Paige yes representative
hamr yes representative Hamlet yes
representative Mirad yes representative
Bay yes representative Brennan yes
representative Grill yes representative
Howard yes representative rter yes chair
chairman Barry chair votes yes with that
the motion exped to legislate passes 19
to0 I'm going to close uh I will handle
the committee report I'm going to close
the executive session on House Bill 170
for that concludes our business as a a
moment of notice uh we have two
executive sessions on Tuesday um that
will that will conclude all of our early
guys